goodmorning character now one more thing i
am things were joseph ramen
which the sampler the louder he who through
the cd for the new apps cyber security
and presenting with joost
andré jr
my name is roger an applet is intro
albinos in the back and helping in your
greenhouse dingos must present the new
cybersecurity with new
concepts the not for cybersecurity on
change whitelist radiates
amber bleeds the computer beak and the
19th is in this new network password
disadvantage is cool idea of ​​a whole
book for the and so the  acting in pure
never knew you were and now is the
consulting public and program management
trainer we specialties education arie
service management at ibm global
infrastructure management design with
about it echidna him experience the back
at ik
ik het in itil enderby cubi three
people services manager  life cycle in
php unix unibet ps primary classes farmer
sofa de in news from duffel go very
broad spectrum
trust shyer new so for my
webinar
he lives in the field of boarden panel
in the shop located in program
whatever name i am not a sailor
let's go  so we have two pins say
hi the andrew the environment here is the
second the figure it's like they
snow white rebuild us the table checking
there just a
zero there will also have food here really
solid noise noise noise
and also this is a nice  program in axel
also food do you have anyone here today
this question mark if your best friend
and go ahead of you have any questions
on your own personal create a bril spa
die box giovanni expert group i
discovered i don't have in public piet
santing ankle  ipad air
sometimes be able to dress there is your
seat in the say betty have 50
military p&o at itris media the patient
we know keeway section which could you
something as i'm really interesting there
are fall and winter shirt to your
social channels
orange  social tennis arm facebook
linkedin tweet
you can now ze fiercely sl weapon arts die
people can find a new mix in which
they were here' you in come here lesson
number
i'm proud to introduce and realize their
job i hope to go head a super relax
do we have hoods capio tea or maybe if i
would you can enjoy glass of wine is
a poor family them so that you thank
you and happy learning and now you hear well
here you see my coding kudos do
and or your home
axel f
alright yes  is welcome everybody
chronic talk about
cybersecurity in present where
and how much it offers from the bee lol
this doodle date
depending on a few knew
my name is andre patentleer
and
with your for the lord o well who
built the ear by something the fashion business  drivers
things that make businesses in mind in
cyber security
what is charlie security we have we
overview
why the two chanel bag is a trillion or
any more
and possibility and traditional style
ipad boring we us r plane that josh
password they hold
oh have overview if the  benefit
vacuum security and also why la choy
in the seas that ar heavily investing
in cyber security plus there
certified professionals
the good news already said here is and who
is she is her also looking for
certifeye
south security professionals
and we have an overview al  so if the
number of strains the disco dixo there's
a type of train i'm standing there you see
a die in the session will do you were
no
if you have any questions
feel free to awesome the item there in that
matter reading about the chip window
our  precious rooster widgets wants
alexander detail and yet pictures
questions in the viewer they cannot see
the mister of mine screen widget
so feel free to jump in any time as
questions
rights
cybersecurity
fascinating topic
and of course it is varus a more than
the prices
and we'  ll well with bart smit saw by the
way
base is that your birthday
and order take here live for the take
4 village we have and then are already
wall umbrellas you have it you
do him puzzles and i believe us incident
management in place
and you can  so also fire fighting of
course that is not good enough interns
so cyber security
and how nice it was
what is the reality in Leeuwarden business
drivers
omar munie
for
of innovations are of course
increasingly de binding online typical
price time and innovations simply cannot
survive has high  tea must much
monastic farmer
so give you and lonely pot
won they piglets smeins in the world
jpmorgan chase
now again my brother my
trillionth dollars and assets
greatest how many
first their high tea must much a
cruise word
hello i do you check the will survive
17  minutes
so full dead he was a witches bicycles
seriously in ss
he must now be at big in 17 minutes why
micro sd how lewis to the so will you
everything where the suykens
has the righty much she chose the board and
that she simply cannot afford me  it and
that is why they
in 16 high he doesn't even works like
itil
for nothing up on service management that
already so in cyber security picos are we
security of frost louis real base is
hobbies business concessions en high tea
process the
many organizations and lines with  you
dance company ladies
a highly de ben a ton never ie
so why is a high visibility
much here
hot yor a whole week in hotel your cupboard
and the jeff beck nothing more the servers
down the course will depart
carlo check your it and your eyeliner  is
simply not acceptable
increased complexity of the ideal for
search
these are different driver
complexities of course with the great
friends
als mr mersey
up again dear mersey
mister money never sleeps with the mersey
is looking in the echos en courses of je
for infrastructure
waiting for oppertunities  tools avatar
sphinx
and missed mercy of course
works closely together how the viewers
and om can you even cyber the tackers
so that they had good and the more
complex your infrastructure the more
opportunities the will be for your
miss him tomorrow have it at home
none the  drink journalist from hackers to
attack
and those who don't want to be successful
surprize european closet in what wise
hackers and
and the sweat
security
conventional security
well a security
and
cybersecurity is but the simple tap
i click clicks into this complex world
time for me the bottoms a  camp also
a search function red nations
hackers terrorism
basic u this is a form of terrorism
industrial and muscles was is an alarm
like if security management the water
blessed young
girl of course risk security aware
that here and we will succeed our cutie in check
three dots cloud  into the images
and you wide open to war ein sof trends and
higher will it is already so state and per
use this knuttel his oil is here from
customers
maybe intense lee because intenser ii oc
security risk
suppliers don't forget that
supplier that they  the hash righty note
series secure
with my jari lion te omnes services
take it with you or something
oh she is if you leave you with
foreign garments secret service
activities at show hello to his
claim
telfort there is a purposes marketing
they say the alarm is sounding and the
season testing  or he so systems
reasons candles ar oh hell no
bladezz
me with the pistons natural that last one
is which he so much sector may
opened she to go no so hunger
bilities and jets
so what is cybersecurity what is wim
all this crisis nothing if then here
in tea  -cup there is ie there is
something kss the newest game place
and resources
that are going to
proactively identified utrechts protec
series of toe and like a cover of
eye and so early abilities sets
and just as
moon feel that they let
proper cybersecurity implementations
means that or your system's are
constantly wat it
clean cybersecurity bill john drives
mountains and mountains update
the latest be processed in real time
and that's one of the biggest the
challenges of blood security
solution of security people small help
in so and cut product offerings to give
your  dress you take when all
it so dish and a firewall want context
to a port bases double
by case number continue number
fours buy and then hackamore user toe
with
get so script forest
concert week and i yo access not able to to to
see that and youtube you  be
your ipad i say and on that testing is the
theory that blamed them it had to grow
like you're in for social science about
within design the gate and user and usual
gate and tail exploiting the
bed-side and security for more it is the
integration of olies classic tools en de
mar en tools and techniques
to make make it be modified at home
and discovered in real time and discover rose
saville platforms such as the mohsin board
and karteria for cyber security and the
tools which is of course integration
integration with your legacy  systems
integration how to turn off your legacy firewalls
and sets
using correlation and jeans the lot
friend and analysis strange region and
servaas hair to mount the en forces
and duckweed technology and duckweed services
et cetera and then you are
marketing
or presiding over people who complete new
business  driven valverde die
why am i chose of course the business
este es vision
determines the rider level of security who
how and who from the guys to decide what
this could in or
the switch of course time is getting
most who matter what level
and how  much financial impact
you can also in much money i must
complete the cyber security vision your regret fortune arm is it's unique
lector of things'
third force mercy will
task in the different way and receive and
the term for this is cool was to kravitz
is  here picture yourself a grouse
picture parents air and cheese sandwich and
what have you got in your putin huge followed
by instant it at
arms steele tenzin tents say looks
very a crash the modern force the
hacker
how barnes
the is very high  along to
or race okay worth security bus around
and compasses
boredom in when yes be safe
everywhere so
business live
the business oil a humbug
observation and play our cutie
how much you can spend to availability
management
their time in a daze the technique and
processions joest in service management
framework slim itil okay and west
want to want team management sup ty
continuous we team management for designers
for a many want the finals
security management the shoot their the pen
had to their the pen obese processions
influences in will with is that which of
course best  deal
white vans greeting security you
take off your coat
implementation to it influence you
icy preferably a service management
implementation you
drop off the base is a robust
he is already 20,000 ruby ​​does with rick does
stendert
to go for sr business
you can that kind of  hot for ice
car that 1,000 which implies that you
have
and effective and efficient
service management implementation for you
as nice itil
arts lanting as
and ice also what is one to keep
which each year the procedure that
management is that i cookbook so the
code of conduct for security management
try good start people the there is
then become time well that's what
cybersecurity at the you can girls
for security management and everywhere
security strategy of
life when the business travel business
strategy
so it's not something like music unity
wel  will not be a gentleman about planning
and architecture of how will be secure
interpretation gents at the multi-layer
holistic approach
integrating legacy and
becoming tools such a thing in tour
cybersecurity toe
the news bearing sets de these hun de pin
this to enable
angry high tea and business processes and
like  service megens for me so
that's
cybersecurity
my training its
own our business challenges in
maintaining security is the fact that the
lens god is cost the changing the oil
constant is change
just like einstein of youth were you
real oil does it cost you first with
change
well so be one who is cybersecurity
okay in the cyber security more in the
world of sugars
sugars
epic it fixed
assistant pride
the citizen challenge first it costs you
updating technique and
ways to penetrate
security systems especialy refute
see
yes we would the biggest challenge  is the
we the battery cover
designing the right architecture of the
single hooks text maintaining it and
updating it bleaching solution the
economical solution
that is a lot to dynamically cost a text
cheeks
talk of course we don't de for peace hey
we the people of wifi
stuffy  people you can do is of
course it was the highly measure us we
're identities don't stand here
and cut it like a partner management
like I now have to where does
n't lead here
artists it's 232 internet to which they
turn off the center
monsieur our ant processions
production technology
product and partners sup mighty avengers
the fall app will deliver service
service is the ear
parents the season 6 and that caesar
absolutely crucial
to cyber security
[Music]
and forth
just like service management processions
security is completly at is all whose
lives come that
inview  channel manager you can not
manage
ryon oh the tank obamas write
down shall not be in artist offline dat
next i find him to man specially
for managers
nou money na sour
you must be able to measure this dat
and white measure of rate number built
agence
number built in
sensors to audio function
correlation engines in in turk meeting
thanks dat er things that in search'
looking at ease and sloops je the
incident
singles en situation color and drawing
appropriate action free programs as for
business rules p'raps en thor escalating
is
automatically to incident management we
were necessary and security with
access management all over the world who are more
in the center and thatcher so here
alive come on here is the money
measure you must be able to measure if
you can measure
you can not manage it is that simple
those who quality management
sometimes have to turn off their nose for service
turn off
use your matrix die cosima a team
patrick soccer and sure you
so beautiful in the sea 6 parts drive here your
aise on petabytes of did a security
detail
first be processed
zo nou challenger en  thou shalt use the
correlation engines
i see don't use these tools
you can do it
security management cbc beauty
broccoli
igor since far too much
yes wave an ethical but a consented
classic tools
hair wet hurt does it
what will be based will it
or you  stupid 3 marcel
essentials
hackers like iq's de vase al released
resistance
though he can assure you that is
absolutely not to use now what he
did he is that is absolutely not taste nature
and humor
reality shows that hackers my
game and free to enterprise systems to
heating ventilation and air conditioning
system stand where the form of jury
this season
we have the cable eye first goal to
very large
eye-wear hackers what access to the
building ahci see system which was
connected to the internet and to that
system think what access  to the heck and
is just as crazy and is your car the network
that works or not properly segment it
like tape and the second the firewall
access to op racing incredibly cost
millions
and i are on we stabbing
ar thank you for something where i have a
10,000  score from hands stockings
credit card deta
was stolen
we are for they the night shift you belong
to
another curb at accenture essential
who connect him well in a company
sorry guys
passwords do the on the security make
and the more you stability
showing us dollar rest
we  it's not you don't want to win a world
tour then
hacker and counters party rents
to before it's high tea the boom all over
the neck strict
well that's a role simpson that so
highly motivated professionals die zeist
though funder
though first it ideal for some time
without  at nation states and very
persistent a professional in the
efforts to break through the border is
and her can assure you a very well you
in fact same mars so good that he her
directly hyatt where security partners of
certain organizations and pete away very
well six  say segers and salaries
first keeper for the cobb reseller because
yolo
i have
a different job levels have a sister
that is course is fire at mr mersey
mr marvel how went state is you piece of
truth in the set
no omari want to see for that dep it
will already cost  that is nonsense
the buzzer lived have a sour is
narsingh
sister looking at
hacking find it
hood in that here is your home cell at the same time
ceo that 5% problem that or bx
and that was a couple of years ago she is
already wieringen
[Music]
get  so eh simon the tank look like what
is the life cycle of a pure time is
at home so who can have a
training gravel planning but nice or
their organizations
and that neo-cons agree him
and the most are doing research
and select a guide
using  fishing technique fall
exacting public information from the web
or perhaps your linkedin profile
buyer website as well as irons forces
nice use the site to extract
information grown and potential but
potential target and proposal
have very specific tools will scan for
network folder abilities like you store
their
cabin and the fever and dust rocket services
applications at
the one extra she's what a party and
delivery or
so there was such a frozen want to see
at stadium looking at the masses have
use and site we both don't allow
the cold for  is apel
in a simili
innocent final sale
paul's layers pdf for ludo will or te dis
kshs child war and the east this
crow's nest emails from your bos
happiness together
see haier and would consult at
people meters the end of penny from
china
no that was for high  -ranking will give
you
and it succeeds compli we this does it
another way i is add some salt
cathy attention of safari white setting
dna is a shed and be interested and
and memories fund that capitol house
emails websites links
prices that can be worn
assets arts about
my ex five six exportation soon it and
access will create process activate
with tacos
when the 16 stiff access to n02 your take
control of this own music and it can
be true and air conditioning
and you will be surprised to in those people in
the  cold no if they are unable to be there is
extra is and so
we do read fill in and drive
priligy
first how nice is
it sweet processes within the system
i would have an easily
access
buddha being detected
maybe at hope imports and they also had
a they  tracks sign use
would you normally be fire protection and
sit because we know between
the and khamani control
create and backchannel trudy internet of
dear backup systems to is pacific
server
so thick and communicate an ipad app for
and and finally actions on the more on
the object  is
and i about to a small she motivations
no north unwise live in many cases is
not the [ __ ] off it
the candy industrial muscle house
eyes or did
adhd we really blame know dating
mostly the detail here
it set so plot
it like the doe die pour
critical  infrastructure
of the reasons nice text blue hey
transformer substation in us
we have able to penetrate the network
of that and the provider and those sites
with oil those kind of wells buringa
piece
it like your store extortion by creating
4 for you
too as if next to easter the  many of these
hackers
professional criminals and they should be
treated search
so in short
look in this lens in to day
business and fire the original
starline leave home beerse and the
traditional security solutions hair in
effective and protecting and paul is a
cloud and  finance
but then series but i say we the
chapel this chose
customers at
oh how you icq public was who disturb old
detail the cloud
harry
what is the cloud
the cloud is ie internet wow
so storio city of somebody else's guy
who where the course that  such a car
went worth makes it more secure by
definition
sorry that's what exactly so far
so ready storage in the self
agree to your liking theory denen see us
and that's what coco beckham is all about hey
but who they the spread perhaps and themselves on
us need access students
so this is such an additional entire neighborhood that
here and so
with in terms of security
so never guarantee in technology on your
dating you malfunctions on a sandalias sister
stuff and has the snot wel project that
the first so so
what she  do for
last do
funding' of course
mini the bags moby dick sugar monica
i a show you this is not the right
in vest in tuesday
what does the beach unity this process
everyone who is not availability management
you continuously we tea access management
incident management you  not such a small
the or enterprise-class
framework so manifold is
toe some oil to enable your business
process is this already so to secure
your en dimension titles in the sailor
by the way they it's up to how
the right code contract for security
this is a procedure people do
cream
well known no risk assessment with the
mad gee
use in security management in its
mainly service management and frameworks
like itil cobit
strether who are positions and from the
base lesbos who in place this is business
three dogs of course  i who the champion
in where is it for you support is
that i was this is not something you the
site dan a wine i am i live in
question cybersecurity week was double
fire your coming i you have
mastered wheelspin the 16 channels and say and  you
hash toe invested in the benefit's
run-up toe
and mattie because arrow is a symbol
because there activism
valerie she where you're not true must be
commitment for that tunnel is
with our orders those external parties try
your luck your
accountancy for one and the season
testing 5 archive
saying
hennis of security and why music you this
so from the camps that educate your closet and so
actually fill in customers and
external not who
from that stavenisse trains more artist
to something more certified management
services their vote this I  was in view
is now in beater security management
hear i went so far with availability
continu we 10 access manager application
management at set so from sector
youtube or when her to do start it
's cold how you do has or become the
customer things they want
and  becomes management and so during the
first ida the management between the
existing staff yes
no we also have as a fractions
misery
implementing in they do
become for suppliers tools with which we tools
very chic unity platform
technology of course
and
platform and technology
when geller a  bit nice seatools
that something who integrators that person was
mabel to enforce
already old
interactions koalas interactions
between detail and users
of this time i die a segment in your
network whose
multi-post ages of protection
correlation engines
workflow service that are able to
identify trends
location sports users' and those of plaintiffs
golden time wholesale retail real time
and generate security dating
so protection on details have a in
wild post ducklings like the attack
lifecycle angry face in the lifecycle
is detectable
keeps smart set of stress
when was be able to fight  a youtuber
who expresses a youtube thanks
strange your wi-fi pockets
fabric like that the great cold chain use
ssl
hack-a-thon at home try to create a storm'
thatcher horse of an echo
fonda and they can use that some time to
parasites
you  wins aliens the timing gadgets
was be
translated into security policies
real time cfd up to date with
intelligence report actions
easterlittens the text
quick and edit mitigation
incident management this remains popular
is what i stay chase management turned out
so you can quickly
receive a response in a control
turned out beautiful he tex in compression micros in
the video security technology are
busy house of force i have and
if you cost it on a just be who him
summery spacious activity yet firewall
and must be easy to use case djoez' and the
sense
that he too  actually already this data to
wish is to ever so much be easier to
finance theon emily's
the center and or frost the east through
the blocker tour
i was we talking about every platform
and risor with
two oldest campari
mountains update
then i see i see her ivangay
again ring finger the sametime cisco clear
the impossible
you will be ready for the silent in
allocates
a simple so letter you a break
how you third chain pie is it that
time it's software that's called it people
so mythology size
operational and strategic
nl it  analytics matrix
detail people dumount is a model
dating and the benefit's haha ​​lord her
you her on rational analytics at the
same time as the critique of analytics
operational issues
tools that i track
specific networks and events
monetary thinks real-time the text i
were  jean-pierre stress on the pedigree
aesthetics and then it x could you
say about time
you and energy strand and alice is for
the stairs up and along punish iris penning
decisions and require
all the time and cost that connekt it
actually agents in turgot it and
percent it a recorder to
and the boot crucial
osd soldier is a place and
right now the subsidy i ability in the
organization the
get right people the we process is
exactly that is a technology place to
context networks and date-a-thon detect
attacks
and  therefore week and persevere concept
of china
multisensor italy agency which
coffee grounds consumer charity
in technology and availability over the
charity mee is of course
deta the chest strap a conference is
again accessible to those that
ever rises to her geert
so three most janitor in technology
whose so stiff  10 so wie je date a
very important and availability which
means uptime also just very ability of
systence a lot of wind die of services
ndt nou
arts and the passion and
certifications her lot of views
ladders kan je bits she slept angry
something complex fall on x y z
rise above  you should
hear that there is an implementer
certification and from
with in stennis institute word not good
certified literal crazier wie
jesus
hi mary
and of course the ground you
of security
hoe die de certified information system
security professional de cia ss tee
white ink
certification
a normal forms one is for pie the
view the information security manager
say i'm sorry party
order to leave you want the ears suppose
you we for an account easy for you
wanted to
the season testing services is that often
you can your information systems  shorter
you also find that for that certification
signal you she
has johan highly technico you working
for belt management support luxor
incident management or perhaps service
level management
terms of
service management framework stan your
video for ie he security plus
certification
which is under techniques label and  so
nice protocols
keep your problems routers
as long as i want and i see hard manager
that managers engineering on people
the dc years alessi
certification when just think you
so sweet out in math information
systems control
those are a number of which a lot of lot of
training censorship deviations
from
viewpoint of several roles have
a good bases how who the certifeye ted
waste own
who was you a form with the tools
the use
what you're a natural hair frost
you not happy
and i see what she the feel crack he becomes
she de cia iss pi is a vene well very
highly regarded
certification for security professionals
this leaf
ear that there can also be interesting
wifi were consultant and je provider
dose services
to customers
yes so the couple of sables u
wire certifeye professionals private
especially the cost that  jane die line sky
with one of the muses search chest your
brain bi-polar become the latest
and greatest in the leaders en for many
businesses
wine hiring security state
7 qualifications are already kompels
sorry for those provisions
intresting
had to for security professional station
to be certifeye  the cost
ohra die
henk to or six million just in
information security of ready
it is official detail from partner and
arisia institute long bed
and as soon as that one is a lot but
1 april in
of those people and the high one joost
number no six pack  there to the fish that
thousands everything here is good politely
norms
for highly series of security just
with the same
profile critical success factor stanley
no longer turned out that just for security
manager and cybersecurity
with all so for
management framework
the service management eyeworks like home
wit white itil  and lean sixsigma
recipes
excellence communications
absolutely necessary
proper project management white beatles
implementing the stuff is already
he projections and pagans sure you was
die is posies rescue new silent not
on the project was to release processions
and first gate in trials process lies
and project
management community dead  intense disturbance
with her hope
amin is death note management is not
interested in security
he his tail fin is gigantic
microsim by offer best know this fire
it is incredibly expert realize the
benefit's real-time benefits are wolter
and not very visible in the with  matching
your own jubilation sing where your warm cloth
is not hosting all the money
what did the teacher say
dangers and pitfalls when implementing
the star wars' as soon as it style that
people this security must be
where much in when i safe or woman
yes i want to exploit henry week  sports and the
cheney romy the current is the week is long
so long so graceful step or loop
wesley have rough
litter cutie bee design what do they do
he had to fresh and do you want
new rushes price go opinion
operations parents the sections and the
seventies
rhett and  link cable
ar still being used and for swung
open
yes very nice operations we have sivan
legacy platform
de donau secure the f-35 san carlos
security layer a window dressed as
polyester read-write die application
elected tour men hier
countries it would be both the  scope of
very well
with you can sing or a single sign on
service that i keep all those goodies wie
naughty and keepen ton seperate network
checklist or if
necessary security at declaration audi
at
you can they you who that party view
will leave here by whom there is asbestos
spoil and entropy rules
be snapping
the minx
entropy
you mire in nature
when everything cool down for sale
he becomes there flows de muro put in
entropy
diminishing of things like
entropy of the universal because at below
there are new course for you
burn out
what is that she do it cyber
security and if i was
in the issue appreciate and paperless the
men july at the chair
and you then do there is built the limo
i was someone in this company before
this know
yes d'este home the most  tomorrow wiles
like or cost you autumns keep doing
security fct testing the first type of
sheets i don't know holding your tests
the operation of a system one of the
most expensive and security management
nick was you almost intimate doing the henna
voting and rechange in the business
processes  or changing your high tea and
why or services
the house more update the
hunting lodge procession is like chase
management the list
people start changing links sorry we
need that so to the righty he
scaffolding the security go would
windows
security management no dictate things
to order  processing
no march that you can use their eyes already
twelve thousand for service management
for yourself
and those tegans
ethics
how critical role of the business
perspective
cobit is cool is that wooden
floor architecture framework
see him and me
capability maturity a nice
apple has microsoft  operations
framework
software development of all
those who die youtube framework in which
you can integrate
implement security management
cybersecurity ice on 237 by the way here
official
security management stenden codes 100
so criterion risk assessment one is
methodology
revenue can caress your force who is not
project management
project management arjan  well
raving award for you where i jeeves and
become prince of 4 4 pi group i might be
okay it
would it super
oreos
the chest me bridging
so for
excellent excellent
boy and bear apf let the muscles
start we have
clever the mini here is  have a tip
do with tournaments cybersecurity
a loop take 2 ah league
[Laughter]
military coup also working
publication number tassels room in here
lower push in the question single
influences other glare and we draw the
screen for this 5 minutes and launch a
rolling
will  this issue carwash in terms of
finances with politics in the
champollion alterno and crazy have santini
who need on add to screen for
in a pot
hi one hour frames between screaming
european through a single streamy
special about nepalese letters monique
lesjes
weavile are questions asked if you  may
be measured a number a woman
lay bleaching so eyeliner since
european and there then grigio growth
we just
add
it looks in an engineer how it
the new becker engineer have the
numbers i you guys through my like peter
my focus and she engineer  coming up
with a software engineer
i just got you my engineer at psa for
engineer
like an engineer
oc start wit
janneke cybersecurity course
at eagle he went collapse through and
through
add to go operation and follow wraps with the
conti eye for more technical city
okay  who coming from a b names are
the ones who learned him have
already heard many people did you
the map lk
write down
this is also an mri cybersecurity coronation
the bully a well
what is the piglet seriously cybersecurity
this is is coming in to mark the  track
sms
sms monuments outside
the big eyes or add to all this that's
point bloody fortune on it and now the
sme will
realize that they so much
[Laughter]
that watch tv word with extra a startup
razor back small business in
china ella  coming and sitting stab tony
needed time
yes i have a medium for a for [ __ ]
bye
that said you country with five and
even blew in this tune
tattoo i am sigma slender
with you kent ring
anatolia brief
using some too easily
buy them in the people
camille  help the technical staff and
growing engineer
the seaports tpp
new level the murders scribe it the ept
was
the french persistence talent
okay but is so delicious
the discription to bed
why do no
attraction reflection
vetst in the family and i am the one
particular person or
using a shirt and technique for now
because he from the moments
de duo s puffs it's quite for i live
the routine
extra
buddhism in the five employees and cs5
and poetry the hood and i looked
and so he is white is the malware nos do
rather  new
sms a puzzle orc every now and then a
chain and it and regioned
okay a couple of tool something like that time
could sophie and he is
software and transported into a certain
area in the cloud for a couple who will
be executed in he for john harmon and
test  it and what it fits here rather
create use'
that kind of technique want to
and so that is in facility that one of
these tools which security cyber
security tools let
will enable
the also a them tool shed
and them person that would be some money
how
these peeps the something to new
in a controller ai at accor she
okay it looks no answers got
so who windows hahaha and the gallons rivm
is peanuts and you can such a rooms
background so entry pauli web lammers
how it with the  highlights ferraris
were certification so absolute eagle and
for cyber security
the thenns oil bits is meanwhile forest in
two
and his sales you go with me was the
name is a cool street
that is very hard for several they many
many to switch hornbill invite
you  center is another for
that the next generation and the nexttime
people
prices escalates very nicely
yes
men in loading crochet baby will be
ingredients
tomorrow america more
specific request
my number the video network security
engineer working on checkpoint and cisco
firewalls
had to get urgent help  and two
help to boost
my greer is it cms ask your cx
cy a usb mobile access for him
we want prosecution and concealer
okay i will it
my onesies course biology in section
german and you secours'
china
the plenary coverages see you there they
are  more again after singing bids
crackling
cia je 66 auditor
mobile
the band new 6 am you want start
looking but i can't see now who can
also i had to go in tomorrow otherwise here
says sabotage find you do penetration
testing new order ting nog systems
auditing  for syrians
so that how that
clickable if you
provide a service sister your customer or
you work for healthy for and you hired to
or is the security measures in view where
the continue team manager
this stuff you
all get excellent it im going back
to wait a few  more questions and do
you have this beautiful song now both rooms they
have they are neat and full of glamor
wordpress sites and his right i
professional this here is the video ever
got industry
random words or wear so in those people
for the training
luigi justice for
any  rooms and in wordpress sites and
again a specific part
wordpress
so narrow now
and guides smaller company
it's hot
sorry what is it 5 people drivers a
cnc goal hawking and cybersecurity jello
course
excellent oh so gorgeous to watch here
comrade
it
was an honor  ncis
spqr with the css pierce
and he was now true certified secure the
professional
and that is the full blows
security training and certification
to a very high line is widely
further yoga you guys spect it you
can you can compress
with an eastern djs and is worrying
okay  i have i laughed penny
excellent but i the same room action
when the train in this your
titular things as young deer
barrier layout close the attempt lord
that verification lead to and now your
earlier slideshow
no wrinkles
and so then one closed 6 and 4 pushing
cap the session  who can hurt from
mars support desk and you simply line
renaud ten watch' there is a
use idea want to have with a
pony for hours lars and seward in us
jolink for
glenn close zentangle barry shipping
happy living in tank hem sampler